[Música]
hola bienvenidos aquí a américa el
magazine de france 24 para realizar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente yo soy natalia
cabrera parada y esto es lo que veremos
hoy
empezamos en el norte del continente en
eeuu porque la corte suprema de justicia
anuló el histórico fallo roe versus wade
que garantizaba el derecho a la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo a
nivel federal es una más de una serie de
decisiones controversiales que tomaron
los magistrados esta semana luego de que
el día anterior ampliarán el derecho al
porte de armas analizados
también visitamos el ecuador porque el
presidente guillermo lasso hizo algunas
concesiones al movimiento de protesta en
su contra sin conseguir desactivarlo el
diálogo sigue estancado mientras los
enfrentamientos entre los indígenas y la
policía continúan en las calles de quito
y seguimos en el sur del continente en
venezuela porque nicolás maduró eliminó
el subsidio del combustible en la
mayoría de las estaciones de servicio la
petrolera estatal pedevesa ordenó cobrar
el diesel a precio internacional
incrementando su valor 1900 por ciento
vamos a caracas
y vamos de inmediato a eeuu para nuestra
historia principal la corte suprema de
justicia anuló el derecho al aborto a
nivel nacional tras revertir el fallo
del emblemático caso roe versus wade que
desde 1973 protegía legalmente la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
hasta la semana número 24 de gestación
los magistrados argumentaron que la
constitución no hace referencia al
aborto y deja en manos de los
gobernantes estatales la decisión al
respecto el presidente yo bailén aseguró
que este viernes es un día triste para
la unión americana e instó al congreso a
reactivar las protecciones de roe versus
vuelta escuchemos sus palabras
hoy es un momento muy solemne no es una
exageración hoy la corte suprema de eeuu
le quitó expresamente un derecho
constitucional al pueblo estadounidense
que ya lo había reconocido
no lo limitó simplemente se lo llevaron
eso nunca se ha hecho con un derecho tan
importante para tantos estadounidenses
oliver
barrow versus way reafirmó los
principios básicos de igualdad de que
las mujeres tienen el poder de controlar
su propio destino y reforzó un derecho
fundamental de privacidad de cada uno de
nosotros para elegir cómo vivir nuestras
vidas
ahora que row se ha ido seamos muy
claros la salud y la vida de las mujeres
en esta nación ahora están en riesgo
pero el fallo no fue una sorpresa se
veía venir tras la filtración en mayo
del borrador de la opinión de los
magistrados en un hecho sin precedentes
que dejó ver su intención de revocar la
sentencia la decisión que afecta al 58%
de las mujeres en eeuu que están en edad
de concebir fue tomada por la corte
suprema estadounidense que integran seis
hombres y tres mujeres pero no fue esto
lo que dividió el voto precisamente
también seis a tres sino la tendencia
conservadora frente a la progresista
mire el tribunal tiene mayoría
conservadora especialmente tras el
nombramiento por parte del ex presidente
de donald trump de tres jueces red cada
no millward switch amy cón y barrett
mientras que los jueces stephen breyer y
sonia sotomayor y elena kagan criticaron
duramente el fallo y dijeron que
disienten con tristeza
recordemos el caso roe versus wade en
1969 a los 21 años una mujer llamada
norma mccorvey quedó embarazada por
tercera vez protegió su identidad con el
seudónimo jane y solicitó autorización
para interrumpir su tercer embarazo en
el estado de texas el fiscal del condado
de dallas henry white rechazó la
petición argumentando que sólo se podía
interrumpir un embarazo si la vida de la
madre estaba en peligro la defensa de
mccarthy presentó una demanda federal
argumentando que las leyes estatales que
prohibían el aborto eran
inconstitucionales mientras se producía
el fallo norma tuvo una hija y la dio en
adopción
y para el análisis en aquí américa nos
acompaña mariana ardila ella es abogada
de la organización women's link y nos
atiende desde lima perú quiero empezar
por preguntarle primero específicamente
en el caso de eeuu esto no va a
erradicar el aborto lo que va a hacer es
hacerlo más difícil y peligroso para las
mujeres para que accedan a él el mismo
presidente de bailén lo dijo serán las
mujeres más pobres las más afectadas que
dice esto del país que una corte con una
mayoría de seis hombres tome estas
decisiones por las mujeres
realmente lo que dice el presidente va a
ir en es lo que va a suceder las
activistas que hemos trabajado en
contextos restrictivos del aborto
sabemos que esto no los previene sino
que los hacen seguros y que las más
afectadas son las más vulnerables esto
muestra que eeuu va en contra de la
tendencia mundial es que ha venido muy
fuertemente desde el sur global de
eliminar o restringir el uso del derecho
penal para regular el aborto y además de
hacer su acceso más fácil han habido
cambios de este tipo en colombia ecuador
argentina méxico tailandia corea del sur
y eeuu va en contra de esa tendencia con
esta decisión de soporte supremo y ya lo
mencionaba precisamente entonces este
fallo de eeuu pone a la vanguardia a
suramérica en materia de derechos
reproductivos y qué significa esto
indudablemente en años recientes hemos
tenido en américa latina' decisiones muy
importantes de altas cortes como las de
colombia a las de ecuador a las de
mexico que han progresado en materia de
derechos reproductivos estas decisiones
que tenemos en el sur global debe ser
ahora que no ha caído los referentes
mundiales en materia de avance y
protección de los derechos de las
mujeres las niñas y personas con
capacidades de estar ella es mariana
ardila muchas gracias abogada de la
organización women sling gracias por
acompañarnos en aquí américa de france
24 a ustedes por la invitación y en otra
decisión polémica esta semana la corte
suprema de justicia estadounidense anuló
un control al porte de armas impuestos
en el estado de nueva york argumentando
que va contra la segunda enmienda de la
constitución la decisión permite que los
ciudadanos porten armas en la calle en
defensa propia 25 estados del país
requieren un permiso para portar armas
en público incluido hasta ahora nueva
york- el congreso aprobó proyecto de ley
para dificultar el acceso a armas a
personas peligrosas en un inédito
acuerdo bipartidista que llega tras tres
décadas de inacción en la materia y en
medio de un auge de tiroteos masivos en
la nación norteamericana
vámonos al sur a ecuador el país está
paralizado por cuenta de las protestas
antigubernamentales
lideradas por la confederación de
nacionalidades indígenas del ecuador
conaie que exige al gobierno de
guillermo lasso controlar el aumento en
el precio de los combustibles que
recordemos está al alza en todo el mundo
atender el desempleo regular los precios
de los productos básicos y también
combatir el crimen organizado entre
otras demandas leonidas iza es el líder
indígena que convoca a las
manifestaciones sigue condicionando el
diálogo a que se levante el estado de
excepción que el mandatario ecuatoriano
ordenó para hacer frente a la situación
lo cierto es que se trata de un círculo
vicioso pues los bloqueos están a su vez
generando incremento de los precios de
los pocos alimentos que continúan
estando disponibles nuestro corresponsal
en quito- gustavo ortega nos amplía
agustín pas millo no ha podido
reabastecer su puesto de verduras y
vegetales en el mercado popular de la
ciudad de quito las movilizaciones
indígenas que comenzaron hace más de una
semana está llevando a perder su negocio
por la falta de inventario
los productos
nos llegan los alimentos y lo poco que
llegas llega muy caro a veces el precio
del precio original
otros con menor suerte han decidido
cerrar su puestos y ya no cuentan con
alimentos para vender y la situación
tiende a no mejorar cuando la
distribución del combustible está
presentando un retraso ya siete
provincias del país tienen problemas de
abastecimiento según datos de la cámara
nacional de distribuidores de derivados
del petróleo
pichincha es una de ellas y los usuarios
comenzaron a tomar sus previsiones ante
una posible escasez comprar incluso unos
galones de 4 o 5 litros para poder
llenar la gasolina y tenerla en la casa
de reserva porque no se sabe que pueda
pasar con esta situación pero otra parte
de la comunidad indígena de ecuador se
está viendo afectada con los bloqueos
víctor que maneja un emprendimiento
familiar de venta de artesanías y cuyos
productos provienen de una de las
provincias declaradas en emergencia se
cuestiona si debe salir a las calles o
proteger su negocio también es justo no
es
es por una remuneración justa para el
trabajo del campo que no es bien
remunerado y por otro lado en mi trabajo
en mí en mi enfoque del trabajo que es
el turismo ahí nos vemos los otros
afectados las luchas indígenas con un
componente histórico de la protesta
social en el ecuador que han logrado
derrocar cuatro gobiernos las más
recientes se produjeron en el año 2019
por las mismas causas que hoy consideran
y satisfechas esas demandas no cumplidas
afectan agustín que espera que las
movilizaciones no le obliguen a cerrar
los días pasan y el conflicto aún no
avizora una pronta solución precisamente
ante el aumento de precios a nivel
mundial el gobierno de nicolás maduro
eliminó el subsidio del combustible en
la mayoría de las estaciones de servicio
de venezuela la situación preocupa a los
sectores productivos
especialmente al de los pescadores que
ha visto paralizada su actividad a los
transportadores y a los distribuidores
de alimentos que además deben lidiar con
la escasez de gasolina recientemente la
petrolera estatal pedevesa y no a más de
100 estaciones cobrar él dice el precio
internacional incrementando su valor en
1900 por ciento el informe desde nuestra
corresponsal en caracas daniela zambrano
jorge luís rico desde hace 35 años es
pescador pero con la eliminación del
combustible subsidiado ve en
dificultades su negocio el gobierno está
otorgando 120 litros de gasolina al mes
con esa cantidad la pesca pasó de ser
diaria quincenal las jornadas más largas
y los recorridos más cortos antes venían
a diario hasta 3 tanque iba y venía se
le fue mal bueno volvemos a equipo pero
hoy en día tienen que quedarse en la mar
un día dos días tres días
para
para poder hacer la campaña a unos 65 km
en la capital la situación agobia a los
comerciantes de alimentos
cristian montilva vende verduras y
hortalizas del sur occidente del país en
este mercado popular de petare
trasladarse unos 900 kilómetros a la
capital es cada vez más difícil por la
escasez de gasoil que se registra en el
interior de venezuela el precio pasó de
0.10 a 0.50 centavos de dólar el litro
un monto difícil de pagar
la bombas hoy en día en el táchira están
totalmente cerradas básicamente una o
dos en cada pueblo funcionan cada 15
días la única manera de conseguir en el
táchira es gasoil colombiano el impacto
se siente en el costo de los alimentos
que han aumentado entre 20 y 25 por
ciento en las últimas semanas el pescado
pasó a ser un producto costoso para los
venezolanos oswaldo cuenta que las
ventas han disminuido y algunos
proveedores tenían incluso llevarles
mercancía a la capital les resulta más
rentable venderla a colombia
tres días haciendo la cola para gasol
encima
de los guardias
y tengo lo real así el gobierno nacional
ha ido sacando progresivamente del
precio del combustible subsidiado de las
estaciones de servicio el valor de la
gasolina dolarizada ha aumentado para
los comerciantes en 1900 por ciento el
precio que se ve reflejado en toda la
cadena de distribución de alimentos y
que afecta directamente a la mayor parte
de la población que no tiene acceso a
dólares
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa en la producción estuvo
luis fernando montes pueden ver esta
emisión y las anteriores en nuestra
página web france24 puntocom por favor
envíenme sus comentarios en redes
sociales a la dirección que viene en sus
pantallas para más información de
nuestro continente sigan viendo france24
[Música]